ça c'est quoi c'est ça ok je risquais de
masquage l'as cannes a obligé avec le
pad aussi plutôt que de se faire chez
moi je préfère me faire chier non j'ai
du mal à jauger la solution c'est mon
jeu que j'ai juste peur au caire a mis
d'accord ok je me suis fait un nom de
cartes en fait de work well c'est clair
que sans carte t bank il efficace
y'a pas en tout cas ce qu'aiment ici non
non ok on décampent c'est parti on va
continuer on est capable avec je te fais
c'est simple si je ne traînerai et
violon jean bélanger on va passer
est-ce qu'on peut passer par la fenêtre
et pierre bref alors c'est lui qui peut
grimper
tu as les effets optiques à le faire
sont réjouis en tout cas ça ressort
lente et dans tout ce truc très très
sombre très très glauque
ça fait pas de mal aux multi alors est
ce qu'il peut pour une fois les länder
les chefs peut-être un jeu
on va essayer de les voir ici un truc
voilà un huissier
à l'aise ouais monnaies c'est encore un
tel carton jaune car nous a joints
hockey est apparue un jour des trucs
foggia les la chance avec arrêt n'est
pas ok ouais je sens le camion il va
devoir nous avons d'affaires tout ça et
moi se chie dessus comprenant toutefois
ce qu elle s annonce pas scannés fallait
qu'il avait un sens évident quand je
suis tombé de [ __ ] à mon petit coeur
mon petit coeur au [ __ ]
en plus je les dis je le sentais c'est
que mandé space et truc c'est vraiment
un truc de syndiqués à cheval en dessous
parce que je suis un espèce de mecque
qui me vient chercher tous les recoins
non c'est une très mauvaise idée nous
traitons blessé je le sens on sait qu'on
va entendre et là dans un protège-dents
belgique de hockey bien passé pour la
porte soit donc tieger a eu peur ok ils
sont encore quelques ajouts soir
ouais j'en jusqu'à ni vite fait et j'ai
bien fait quelque chose à scanner ouais
until carte ya rien à scanner enfin ya
un élément donc d'être le gagnant ne lui
manquait on va alors de spi on veut rien
les sites approché raffin yako et c'est
ok bon doit pas chercher pour ces trucs
on va chercher la forme rien de cassé
j'en assume ratisse un super utile en
cas d'invasion tombes des fonds soit
avec nos jours alors on a mis sa voix
retrouvée ce parti on est touché c'est
bon temps à torcy
quoi que je fasse quoi là bah oui baba
ami est pas fou de jeu faut que j'ai
décidé au ketchup
alors on retrouve dépassé largement dans
les c sipa vers ça j'avais même si ces
générations sont vite instructions
laissées pour ça me semble craquer en
plus rares
relativement les égouts - qui avait
démissionné dans les égouts qui se sont
contaminées à ces séquences comme dans
the walking dead et la jespo l attention
c'est quand même joué vite elle a
devancé de 10 secondes
le virus se transmet tournée portent le
virus seulement il se révèle une fois il
est mort mardi
alors j'ai pas envie de se caler chaque
pièce avec le cric un petit peu chiant à
faire je pense qu'on les beaux objets on
peut chercher manuellement
ouais mais le fuit on est d'accord
c'était ça la piège au début on est
retourné en est au tout début
actuellement
ok parfait kla de avoir plein de choses
à voir
enfin
ok c'est bien donc ça c'est un accord
mecs congo dedans et
je découvre en jouant cher john je suis
déçu mais je ne pense pas qu'on sera
d'accord sur ça quand tu vois dans la
paix elle est l'occasion de la terrine
cochet tandis que moi de moi tu vas
manger ça
how well as tu dis ok piètre asie mais
révolte inquiète la bombe de peinture ou
la décrire le sage sur les murs le cd
symbolique pour communiquer en ligne
avec les autres rescapés
ah ça c'est super si les bons pour
appâter stemmer ok on a tout pris je
pense il ya plus rien à moins que non
seulement ça va là bas il faut qu'on ait
plein dans ok on m'avait juste revenir
pour un peu tout ça est ce qu'on peut
aller ailleurs on va retourner ici
oui c'est parti on retrouve marché j'ai
un peu claires
vous cache cache et reader x ça sent le
cac a selon moi
e
tu roules stresse un peu général en tout
cas le milieu de la maniabilité je
dérive c'est cool est vraiment cool ex
expression de keke on veut banny venait
pas des pâtes super les quartiers
catholiques renfort les pâtes sont pas
mal écarté tout me flaus habitus
franchement ça passe bouquet alors c'est
bon on est d'accord qui ne demandent pas
le badge appels entre temps un
chargement ça veut dire que je vais
sûrement contre et cher je n'ai jamais
une porte lui aussi haut parleur mais
c'est le foot chez finale faut voir en
trois matches la bataille bat à bata
bastien k
tiens bon tu la fermes 4000 m tu es
moche toi roma ces policiers voulaient
pas me réfugier ça alors là ce groupe là
bas je pense que oui parce qu'il y aura
un zombie je suppose que mais aussi sa
masse faire quelques emplettes en titre
de l'autre côté avoir germain ok on va
on va passer
aes pas chose nouvelle
ouais ouais
et rouste à côté
voilà je suis charge des scans et je
vais faire des dossiers instruits qui va
arriver là elle est full swing swing
votre willunga oui c'est le belge était
sur sa piste en regard de notre mieux se
déplacer à d'autres voient passer par
moments on a des fusées éclairantes
alain bagnoud super les tout ça dans la
sondeuse ils sont deux concurrents
poussée des coûts dans la soupe plus bas
ces deux objets gens un autre parent
terme voire des serpents et échelles
parce que taylor jeudi sous la menace et
une mini chute et qu'on a perdu de la
vie pour descendre à terre à terre tous
beaucoup gogo qu'au hockey ma tante et
sa répartition
ça
4gas mme castot les castors tient sa
faim 3 6 6 1 c'est exact c'est bon
maintenant je pense que je m'en tire sa
valise était deux je pense que quand ils
sont trois quatre fait déjà moins le
malin et quand ils sont 600 tu te chie
dessus alors on te passer ici oui non je
l'étais sur la voiture j'imagine la cité
grattant agentique année les lieux mais
bon dans une plaine voyage toujours un
nouveau dans la benne est ce que il y
aurait quelque chose détecte non rien
ressources inutile un des cartes mises à
jour alors j'arrive pas savoir quand et
à quelle époque il ya quelque chose là
je pense que l'arrière
ok je suis passé souvent le truculent
détecter sérieuse un tour plus
éclairante non j'ai juste un desert
eagle un été chaotique mais [ __ ]
dégage dégage ou ou carnet terme un
terme à lui à lui michael bacall martory
j'ai pas de leur temps oui c'est bon
c'est bon
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] y'a pas un fucking
truc elle analysé j'ai pas de plan là
j'ai rien c'est la panique la l'accolade
ans plus tard était tout à fait contre
l'apport de mon retard c'est quoi merde
et votre frère je fais pas je vais pas
été bon alors objet ivoiriens lui les
divans alors regardez regardez lui jure
qu'il écume tiens tiens j'ai brièvement
à terre va je te fais pas être examiné
au pid je te fouilles et voilà c'est
quoi ça c'est un match de mardi à jeudi
un écran qui faisait l'écho quand
j'étais en fait c est toi vous m rigole
la peine de mort pour accéder à ses
justes la rio le marteau
voir marteau et [ __ ] mais forcément
avec les sexes et moi là bas c'est
ballot quoi imaginer dans la vraie vie
tu ne peux pas vivre parce qu'il n'a pas
de marteau il était dans l' il était
dans la poubelle
ok pardon tout ce qui peut à mon avis et
je prends un à un les analyses y'a rien
faut que j'aille là ok foot chinois non
mais non je suis bête mais il n'y a rien
que tu es pas vissé ou vous abonnez vous
retire moi ce week-end touché face à
papa bref un petit coup de radars
d'accord je pense qu'à mon avis ça
marche pas parce que j'ai pas leur
intérieur j'ai utilisé cinq balles de
gueule dans la fac ça sans robbie ça pue
le zombie mais alors là mais je le sens
mais je touche ça tire ça tout de suite
ok sortir non c'était pas la peine non
non non
si on apprendra pas lire les indications
qui à l'écran alors à mon avis si par
contre devant les braves paquet de trucs
à trouver voilà on abat il ya un élément
tout autour d'eux en avoir aussi quand
même ici j'ai respecté cela ici
ressources négatif d'accord ici d'accord
l'étude les ne pas prendre le lait
qu'est ce qu'on va faire
oh il y avait une espèce dont celle où
il y avait une ombre d'un chinois alex
türk a raté la [ __ ] [ __ ] intune
saison quelques jours je n'ai dû fermer
la porte là bas je ne peux plus le faire
aux puces et morges n'est pas bon le
seul défaut un peu la gerbe sur seront
pas trop sauter c'est quoi ça dans mon
triple à aux forts vents non merde
j'aurais dû vider sa crunch face à leur
[ __ ] c'est quoi je pourrais vous tirez
à je vais manger aller un truc qui me
tape ça ça fait quoi ça clan
partiellement je m'en fous moi je veux
du permis
remplir une jauge de vie utilisé ces
mots lui qu'elle allait prendre sa place
et de ce qu est ce que tu sais mon vieux
tu toi par contre cash
voilà on peut prévoir plusieurs fois et
tu évites totalement inutile on va
continuer on va retourner là-bas alors
je vais encore une fois remettre la
vidéo je reviens je suis désolé sac ou
alors c'est reparti la jeune fille un
peu dessus beaucoup
alors fallait qu'on aille là-bas le truc
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de machin
inspectés pour que pour que bah j'ai ma
carte en fait donc bah en fait
bah en fait j'ai pas ma carte mémoire
dégage dégage dégage évidemment je
regarde à gauche si la prod ce matin
qu'il est moche je me casse dit si je me
casse dit si je me casse dit si c'est
bon ça ok ok doit avoir des trucs aussi
si forcément négative ces luttes il a
ici à quoi on a gardé nos vins négatif
négatif
la barque négatif négatif médiatique
willaya y avait une ressource up ok
parfait super génial alors oui
absolument rien alors mais ça fait si tu
connais bien je crois que tu seppi dans
le fait donc jeux coûteront manière il y
avait vraiment intéressant à part c'est
quoi ça c'est une porte la corse travers
la vente et les plantes ça ça peut être
très utile je m'en fous je remets à
lumière avant dé dans un but subversif
pascal cette date là dedans fou rire
général assez bon ferme vient d'allumer
bien à part que c'est ultra glauque ce
n'est pas dans leur zone il ya un zombie
qui fils je vous jure que ya un [ __ ]
de zombies qui est ici je vous jure je
rigole même pas va être un oui ça c'est
le truc faut scanner scar leach ok j'ai
la carte
ok ça marche je suis jeté lui les mines
explose aux cadeaux
ok d'accord moi je veux la faire tomber
oh [ __ ] je pense a conclu par
seulement votre jauge de balasy je m'en
fous de ça ça va mettre là dessus non
manquer ça ça emplit partiellement on va
organiser un petit inventaire en est ça
la salle à la mini s'il quitte ici là
deux notes elles sont trois pour deux
slots owen wilson c'est qu'elle avait
envie moi je vous attends pas vu je vais
vous défoncer faire dans la mare belote
par contre faut aller faut continuer sa
route
c'est pas notre truc un scanner afin
qu'une pièce comme ça je sais c'est la
ville que j'ai fait tomber
merci
ouais ok mon goût de super génial
alors faut aller vous faut toujours et
continue en fait dalida s'il continue à
se figer un bouc peur je peux mentir on
va alors qu'affluent les munitions
et bien voilà monsieur alors voir
charges étaient avec lui quatre
histoires qu'on m'apporte grecque au
noël et signent à dos et un [ __ ] son
déjanté sur bada bien je suis défoncé à
gordes au [ __ ] s'ils disent à son caca
george lucas n'a pas changé que tient à
claouey
crève merde
comment je fais tu m'as au [ __ ] mais
c'est assez dur mais comment tu veux
survivre religion alors est plutôt bien
tiré avec une nouvelle série bon c'est
bien ce que je pensais aussi des
nouveaux survivants à chaque fois
mentionné normand mon dieu je me lève à
une belle tête je suis dégoûté
actuellement la carte est pleine donc on
peut toutefois regretter votre façon
j'ai dû arrêter notre petite bosse
basket je me sens trop mal à la suite du
net repli sur un disponible sur ma
chaîne à compter du 31 novembre
soyez nombreux à être présents